yeah I was really out under six well I
brought my camera because I know I'm
going to look badass chimney go myself
our location scouting out here for the
battleground video we're going to shoot
over the next day or so hopefully we
film the video here if we can't we've
wasted thousands of dollars and three
days of our time we're doing a visual
effects competition between pr9 what do
you mean my job is in the chef Ellis
someone younger than you that is he he
didn't last longer doing the same job in
this group of trees by the way from the
other side the great like huddle and
album of the treaty on this area in
general is like okay it's like the
density of trees isn't too intense here
for when you're filming it like you
really don't need much more than that
anyways end up doing it on the hill they
don't advise
we want him on high ground this is the
spot where the group is when they watch
the great drop but like if they're here
they need to see the crate land top of
the hill there and they leave I can't
handle this don't look 25 minutes I've
been saving problems I've created a huge
scene that takes a while to save now
open my secret way no the owners don't
you look I'm running out of time
keep looking yeah check this out I'm
gonna show you something keep running
out of time and running and mine doesn't
have any cool pop-culture references
[Music]
[Applause]
spider lame
my biggest valve isn't ending with
normal maps conflicting with the
displacement maps can't get them dwarfy
added suddenly have 14 cameras in my
scene is my spider missing parts of the
legs what all the white puzzle missing
and it's frozen
hey I just leave it this leg lying over
your own frozen its frozen your luck
can't unfreeze it but you can try
leather crashes nope sorry penny 20mm 45
cars she brought from [ __ ] her phone
20 minutes first we walked around to all
the potential locations
cavitus absorbed areas and now we are
physically planning where each thing
happens you can't make a decision until
you see everything that's why I'm very
quiet on the first half of vocation
stops I was like Fiji to me well a nice
little picture oh well great picture
that's a picture that we just put up on
Instagram yeah it looks pretty nice I
like it while we're on set we always
like to post really cool photos
okay I've actually been obsessed lately
we're taking photos on this dope row it
is so much more fun to take photos on
this GoPro than on my phone the super
super wide angle and the new GoPros
automatically take that fisheye effect
off your pictures so it gives you these
really nice wide-angle high-res photos
that are way crisper and clearer than
anything you can get on your phone and
plus they look really banging you want
to see all the cool photos we take on
set don't forget to follow us on
Instagram a port or digital what what's
down the woods for wood I officially
declare this the location of the opening
of the video now we're free control
flying dude no those are that oh I think
we got our field here but this is super
simple yes we did it
ceremony o'leary okay now go pick that
up and recycle always Leave No Trace
leave nothing behind
except memories keep those keep the
memories we've addressed very baller
don't just leave nothing behind take a
moment and try to make it even cleaner
than when you got there if everybody did
that things would never be dirty don't
do graffiti on natural things like the
rocks at a park that's just like the
thickest really friends my biscuits in
graffiti especially you do hike and it's
a nice place and it's like waterfall and
then someone just like has tagged a rock
your body's like what out here it's like
yeah all you nature lovers this is mrs.
my name's Annie
sorry to all the Anthony's Anthony was
here 2011 let me know if your name is
Anthony in the comments below I'm sorry
while you're at it please subscribe if
you guys like us when I getting irate
and like complaining about things cards
now
more rants hit subscribe care he rhymes
in that funny story
- actually hit us up via email right
after that video we made about his read
review he's actually a great guy he knew
he knew we were kind of like not we were
you know we're not trying to like start
something so he understood it he had a
good sense of humor about it all my
problem is that every time I open up the
octane viewport it doesn't close only
this shouldn't be an issue at all
especially at for graphics cards to you
the ironic part is I was worried I
wasn't going to have something good
enough after an hour I didn't realize I
was going to not have anything makes
feeling better I don't know much of
anything other models of the bullet
wages model that yeah so uh I forgot the
same that time I will my get up opening
up studious max for a fourth time I I
didn't think I was trying to be too
ambitious I just wanted to bring in a
stupid little minecraft zombie in the 4
min I have to pee so bad I'm just going
to delete all my trees I'm going to
delete all the rocks and it's going to
start throwing shapes and throw playing
them polygons textures on there what
[Music]
please do not crash telling a Dorchester
of course you're enjoying this
[Music]
on occasion
how would well if we learned anything
it's the universal truth that VFX are
safe way longer than they say they will
defend something as it turns out it's
incredibly hard to do anything cool in
just an hour
how is the fast an hour of my life yes
both of our images are already up on the
court or Instagram so if you don't
follow us the link down in the
description to go there click the heart
button like it leg leg leg double tap
the photo that you prefer or a thing or
just hit the heart button that's what I
usually do I'm not much of a double
dipper hey you go down to our Instagram
at corridor digital pick which photo did
better Peters will rent the winner will
be a downloadable desktop background in
the next salmon eco vlog it's pretty
much it so go vote
this is the property of the house were
renting the sense and that sense is on
the property of the opposite house
they've got the sign basing us that has
buyer beware this house has many
problems but it's not a contractor so
it's not like a ghost I think that's a
pretty ballsy move to post the sign
facing another house telling its
occupants that there's serious issues
within the house I'm actually I'm really
really sensitive to writing that right
now because I I'm getting a new place I
just got to like will Sam's house burned
down or collapsed due to termites or
will it stand the test of time for
another few years
yeah well I brought my camera because I
know I'm going to look badass feel like
a work address like Jurassic Park or
something
great know what accent
once that process
[ __ ] dope so this are perceptive a
possum
we're perfect lighting perfect camera
motion perfect acting costumes just
everything one shot what was your intent
with those shots we were trying to get
so I'm trying to get a goal for netiq
sanity of a man being chased whoa whoa
whoa whoa
this is not actually a title it does
that so I'm going on it set up for the
shot it's just you and him we're going
to do an opening shots basically still
forced to shoot and then you whip past
camera and he like whips with you
they're like I know generally what the
blocking could be but actually
rehearsing the scenes everybody if I can
do whatever you want [ __ ] fly the
drone around I guess a judge who's is
better on the corridor Instagram met at
corridor digital Instagram calm for
slash corridor ditch
[Music]